when people respond to rationally to
incentives that is not a consumer
protection problem I am Nicholas be for
reason TV today we're talking with Todd
Sawicki Law School professor at George
Mason University and a senior scholar at
the Mercatus Center thanks for joining
us Todd glad beer let's talk about the
Consumer Financial Protection Agency
which is going to be created by
legislation being introduced shortly its
goal is to protect consumers from
out-of-control debt that they might find
themselves in or from nefarious banks
and other lenders who are screwing them
over Elizabeth Warren or supposedly
screwing them over Elizabeth Warren who
would be the person who is backing this
plan a Harvard Law School professor
who's also the head of the congressional
oversight Commission related to tarp
tells us that the credit market is
broken and that consumers can't compare
financial products because they are too
complex is she right or is she wrong
that's the premise of this new agency
and the agency is one of the
centerpieces of the Obama regulatory
financial regulatory reform package
along with things like a systemic risk
regulator that sort of thing there's
sort of a dual premise that's embedded
in it which is the idea first that
somehow the CFP a would improve the
operation of markets by improving
competition making competition work
better at the same time there's a huge
number of regulations there that seem to
sort of follow old-style kind of 1970s
regulation where they would simply
replace what market competition would
produce whatever it is it goes far
beyond how we've thought about consumer
credit regulation over the past 20 or 30
years in this country here is there a
problem with consumer credit or are
people not able to pay their credit card
debts and if they can't is it because
they don't understand what they're
supposed to be paying when you look at
the data one thing is very very clear
that even though people are very
concerned about the growth of credit
card debt over time what we see is is
that the growth of credit card debt has
come about as a replacement or
substitution
of other types of debt that people used
to use so so people aren't piling on
more debt they're putting stuff on
credit cards that in the past they might
have put on a home equity line or some
other even more than that if you think
about say 30 years ago if you wanted to
buy a refrigerator or bedroom set what
would you do you go down the local
appliance store furniture store you'd
open a line of credit you pay it off 125
of dollars a month for 36 months until
it was paid off and probably paid thirty
percent intro thirty or forty percent
interest you might and into some extent
what we know is that those prices were
also embedded in the price of the price
of the goods is their competition among
credit card offers I think that anybody
who opens their mailbox knows that
there's plenty of competition for among
credit card issuers for their business
and so if somebody like Elizabeth Warren
or the Obama administration says we can
make this more competitive and less
regulated I mean it just seems silly on
the face of it's hard to imagine that um
that that market could possibly be more
competitive than it is already there are
about 6,000 issuers of credit cards in
the country right now let's talk about
mortgages because part of the cfp i
would also I mean it's about simplifying
products and and Warren and other people
actually say what we need are plain
vanilla products that everybody can
understand and is the problem in the
housing market or in the mortgage market
is it complex instruments that are that
you know the very people who are taking
these loans I can't understand mortgages
are obviously very complicated products
and a lot of people regardless of their
prime or subprime borrowers struggle
with understanding every single detail
that is in their mortgage one of the
reasons why you get that great big thick
pile of documents interview a whenever
you buy home is because so many of those
are either regulated or mandated by
regulation or have been added in
basically because of fear of lawsuits in
that sort of thing with respect to the
more general point though if you think
about the financial crisis it's clear
that the financial crisis is not caused
by problems of consumer understanding or
consider or fraud defrauding consumers
certainly there were lenders you
defrauded consumers and certainly there
were consumers who defrauded lender
and certainly there were lenders and
consumers who seemed to be defrauding
each other but they were following
larger incentives exactly the the bottom
line will cause the financial crisis
more than anything else was not a
failure to understand what's going on
but the people understood too well what
was going on that the problem that
caused the financial crisis was
misaligned incentives incentives that
created by by Federal Reserve monetary
policy by very state laws and that sort
of thing that provided incentives to
over invest in housing and now as we're
seeing provide incentives for people to
walk away from their houses when they
when they're not worth what it does so
they used to be so in other words I mean
it wasn't that somebody who gets into a
house and then realizes oh my god I
there is no way I can pay my mortgage
rather it was that people were flooding
into the mortgage market because they
knew the government was backing the
value of rock increasing values of their
houses and they were able to take more
risks exactly sure including the bank's
also saying we're going to go out to
riskier lender or riskier borrowers
because we're going to get back
certainly there were some people who got
confused by their mortgages but but all
the appearing in Decatur that was a
small minority what really spurred this
was people responding to the the ability
to get cheap money and now responding to
the incentives that they have to to be
able to walk away from their houses when
people respond to rationally to
incentives that is not a consumer
protection problem is there anything in
the Consumer Financial Protection Agency
plans that would fundamentally change
those incentives there is nothing that
would change those incentives in fact
the whole premise of the agency seems to
be based on the idea that consumers are
sort of hapless victims who can't shop
for credit products and are just you
know overwhelmed by the world and
there's almost a staunch denial the
consumers respond to incentives or the
lenders respond to incentives there is
probably there's at least one sense in
which the credit markets are broken is
that nobody is quite clear what's going
to happen next in terms of regulatory
regimes and what not if there's a lot of
risk everybody kind of sits out waiting
to see how the dust will settle what
should the Obama administration be doing
if it wants to kind of pour oil on the
troubled waters of consumer credit
markets well what they should not do
this what this is going to do is
exacerbate the uncertainty we already
see and it's going to also have the
inherent problems of any bureaucracy
which is it's going to create one size
fits all rules that aren't going to work
a good example is that seventy-seven
percent of small businesses use credit
cards in their operations yet under the
definitions of CFPA all those small
business people out there are going to
be considered consumers and they're
going to be considered to be the same
sort of people who can't shop in any
sophisticated way for the credit cards
that are good for their for their
business and so what you're going to
have is not just a negative impact on
consumer choice and innovation you could
have negative impacts on small business
development than that sort of thing what
what would be a better regulatory regime
well there's a number of things they
could do without creating this whole
huge new bureaucracy number one
certainly disclosures could be improved
the Federal Trade Commission about two
years ago did an excellent study where
they were they interviewed prime and
subprime borrowers and they came up with
a whole list of ways in which in which
disclosures could be improved so that
people could shop in a better way
secondly you don't need to create a new
bureaucracy for this particular product
the Federal Trade Commission for
instance already knows how to regulate
consumer consumer credit third I think
the Republican proposal on this is
actually worth looking at which is the
Republican proposal would combine the
new elements of the cfpa with the
ability of an agency to be able to
regulate safety and soundness issues
what the Obama program does is takes
this the consumer protection mission
away from the Federal Reserve and puts
it in this one new agency but doesn't
think about what impact that might have
on on safety and soundness of financial
institute
shins final question what's in your
wallet how many credit cards are you
packing right I carry four credit cards
in my wallet and I think that's one of
the great innovations is we've gotten
rid of annual fees credit card issuers
compete for my business literally every
time I open my wallet they are competing
for my business and the ability of
consumers to hold multiple credit cards
and to choose the one that's best for
them even on a day to day basis is a
remarkable benefit to consumers and it'd
be a real shame of that if that went
away because of overzealous regulation I
want to thank Todd Sawicki of george
mason university law school and the
mercatus center for talking to us today
for reason TV i'm nick gillespie